[Musique]
puis-je savoir
je recherche une jeune fille elle
travaillait à la Fabrique d'allumettes
et ne la Holmes elle est détective
celle-là on lui appuie sur le Nail en
sort du lait elle a découvert quelque
chose qu'une personne puisse me cacher
et c'est ça qui es-tu
Charlotte que faites-vous ici est-ce mon
enquête ou la vôtre il semblerait que
nous enquêtes soient liées le jeu de
piste vient d'être relancé
extorsion chantage corruption je crois
qu'elle ne fréquente des personnes peu
recommandables
ou pas en tout cas moi je sais me battre
et nolad a toujours adoré mettre la
baguette
mais c'est important je sais ce que
c'est de se sentir seul d'être ignoré
personne ne prêtent attention à ces
jeunes filles mais je n'ai fait
qu'envenimer la situation ridicule tu
dois te trouver des alliés travail avec
eux et ta nature profonde se révélera
maintenant tu pourrais être magnifique
j'ai besoin de votre aide
ne m'obligez pas à me répéter et puis
chanter
tout le monde ici
la croix désigne l'emplacement on se
teste les uns les autres ce n'est guère
aimable
ne devriez vous pas être à l'école
je me demande qui t'a appris à te battre
comme ça
encore un aspect ducatif de notre mère
[Musique]